why hello there wonderful internet
friends ex Erin Murray had this amazing
idea to prank call some popular
youtubers I too thought that was an
amazing idea except there's one problem
us youtubers never answer our phones
thankfully I was able to get through to
a few people
so check out how these calls went leave
me a comment and let me know which prank
call was your favorite hi this is
Bradley from Sports limited I was
wondering if you like to buy a magazine
subscription no thank you
yeah I'm calling some sports limited
actually sometime excute so I'm gonna
give you a trial subscription for free
what do you think about that oh okay no
harm done
anyways you sound actually kind of cute
do you live in the area oh that's so
nice
anyways can you get together sometimes
if you some really really cute how about
this I'll give you a free subscription
the People and Sports Illustrated if you
show me a really really good time okay
where should we meet
hello hello I was just calling because I
lived on the street from you and your
daughter come to my house today and she
kicked my dog your daughter come to my
house today
and she come on my property and then she
kicked my dog and now my dog needs
operation why did she do it I think she
doesn't mind you act stupid
you don't ask them question no you shut
up
you're trying to confuse I'm going to
call the police and then you're going to
go to jail you're shut up you dog hello
hello I have three puppies
bing-bong hi it saw the fat muffin man
there
fat muffin manatee in oh yeah good buddy
of mine yeah we got him
yeah blueberries got him what do you
want to do is sprinkler the blueberry
now are they stuff nice and label jams
up with that blueberry what's that are
you um I can't affair yes I didn't say
anything to deserve that Emily I'm
welcome to the assorted to shout at me
and yell about numbers all right that's
because I wasn't looking for anything
along those lines a little bit of a corn
a corn problem I think there was like a
bit of corn that um was stuck in your
teeth so it was hard to understand then
there was like uh thanks so much for
watching and thanks to those amazing
youtubers for uh you know being a good
sport most of them had no idea that it
was me
obviously because it didn't sound like
me that's it see you guys in the next
video